oh hello everyone my name is Sarah
DeWitt I'm a 16-month student here at
columbia university school social work
today I'm going to be presenting on
issue that's very near and dear to my
heart I'm going to be discussing the
history of Albany's rap road community
which is a historic district in albany
new york i'm going to be talking about
i'm not going to be talking about how my
family came to be a part of this and
it's the story of how my family ended up
settling here this presentation is
adapted from jennifer LeMat who did her
PhD dissertation on my family history
through relevant research and person to
person interviews and i have the book
right here if you guys when you get a
chance at the end want to come and take
a look at it so i'm going to start
talking about the great migration which
is how my family came to live in albany
new york there were two waves one in the
early 1900s and one in the mid to late
1900s and I like this map because it
gives a visual perspective of where the
where african-americans came from in the
states that they went to the states that
they came from are in red which is
Mississippi in the states that they went
to are in blue which was mostly in
California and New York so our story
begins and shabooty Mississippi on this
map you can see the location of
shippuden so this is a typical family
moving from the south to the north
during the great migration you can see
in this picture i'm going to go into it
a little bit more but the conditions
under which they moved many families
left with not even this amount of stuff
some families left on a bus some you
know piled into a car with just a few
dollars in their pocket and there are
many reasons why they left the
self-segregation discrimination lack of
employment educational opportunities
lynching
so this picture is a photo of a family
sharecropping in the south sharecropping
was a big way of disenfranchisement and
we're talking about seeing the days
power and privilege how the dominant
race the white race and the South wanted
to keep their status of power and
privilege by suppressing
african-americans sharecropping was a
major way that was used after this after
slavery was illegal it was sort of a way
to get around it where they would sell
the land to Africa or let the let
african-americans farm the land and
would charge them substantial fees for
farming the wind so they would get money
from their crops but they would end up
owing money to the slaves up to the
owners of the land because of the high
prices this is an example of segregation
I always say I look at the water
fountain picture and say which water
fountain would use this is an example of
the education segregation discrimination
that occurred just the quality of
resources you can see the food this
picture is a pretty powerful picture
this bridge is famous in Mississippi
it's known as the hanging bridge where
many African Americans were hung this
particular picture shows two young
african-american women who were framed
for the murder of a dentist and one of
the women was actually pregnant and they
said that this is pretty disturbing but
they said that you know after she was
hung and she was deceased you could
still for a while see her and when child
moving inside of her so moving on to the
pole migration factors which is a little
bit more positive African Americans were
they they were appealed to the north by
the opportunities that they thought the
participation in government more
employment opportunities outside of
working on plantations greater
educational opportunities in overall
just being the land of opportunity
this is an example of an
african-american being able to vote at
1942 in the north an example of factory
work which was you know something
outside of sharecropping still hard and
intense labor but the better way of
surviving and here we begin our story
how my family all fits into this so this
is Bishop Louis w parson he came into a
large sum he was from shippuden
Mississippi he came into a large sum of
money and at the time it was very
dangerous for african-american man to
have a large sum of money living in the
south so he decided to move up north he
originally moved to Ohio but found that
wasn't the place for him so he
eventually moved to albany new york and
him along with reverend john johnson
would go back and forth between shabooty
mississippi and albany new york bringing
african-americans up to the land of
opportunity so we start to talk about
albany new york which I don't know if
all of you many of you probably know we
talk about policy but it's the capital
of New York State so my family
originally and most of a person
originally settled and downtown Albany
make sure downtown Albany which even
till even up till today it has a very
city like atmosphere not as intense as
in New York City but there was how to
say there was a they weren't very
comfortable living downtown because most
of the people that came from shabooty
Mississippi were from rural areas there
was also a large very large religious
practice in Christianity so downtown had
a lot of drinking gambling and even
prostitution in the early 1900's example
of one of the bars so Louis w parson
found a place in Albany pine bush which
is very foresty area in Albany and blood
a minute of about want to say there's a
little bit over 20 acres of land and
here you can just see this is shabooty
Mississippi and this is a rap road where
the settlement took place you can see
how similar these two areas are so one
of the families that came to live on rap
road was on these are my
great-grandparents Alfred in leola
Woodard they came by car with only a few
dollars in their pocket just a little
bit of food and came up north they
originally like I said live downtown
with my great uncle and Louis w parson
eventually was able to heat as families
were able to afford it he would sell off
parcels of land to them and at first
just because of the lack of income and
lack of resources the land was used for
farming because most of them were
sharecroppers so they found that as a
great source of income they were able to
save a money from that and any other
little side jobs they have they could
find they originally lived in like a
one-room even think there was running
water with their fan with their families
and as they live there and they farmed
and were able to save up money they were
able to buy supplies as they can get and
build the houses because back then talk
about issues of power and privilege
african-americans it was very hard for
them to be able to get a mortgage so
they just had to do things as they can
from the money they had so this is an
example of Alfred with a boat and this
is the house today and then I also want
to go into so this is the house and she
Buddha Mississippi just looking at the
relationship between the North and the
South and why they were so appealed to
the rap Road community now
fast-forwarding a little bit till today
and back then so originally when he
first got here one of the first things
that was done after they were able to
establish the community was to create a
church and this church sort of served as
a place of refuge in a place of
gathering for them to come and
participate in their community and then
going on until today one of the great
things is
annually we have a family reunion that
sort of stem from the church there were
people that would come up from down
south and they put on it started at one
time they put on a big dinner and that
just sort of built start evolved into
the family reunion ever you can see
right here in this picture in the
background that's the smokehouse where
they used to smoke meat they now we use
it to serve food the pit is where it's
like our famous corn that they would
actually back then they would grow the
corn and then boil it in that pot this
is another picture of the smokehouse and
this is these are the kids at the family
reunion I think the little girl I don't
know I can't point to it that much but
with her head turned when the moula
picture i'm pretty sure that to me okay
so then you know through the work of
Jennifer lemac and other people my
family my grandmother my aunts they were
able to in 2003 to have wrap road known
as a historic district in albany new
york this is where i really want to get
into the power and privilege issues and
our roles as social workers so this
distinction was given um because of this
and i think even before that every year
were able to block off a section of the
road for the family reunion so we
literally like shut down the community
so that you know it's just for us people
can go on the nearby roads go around it
but the community is really there just
for one week and every month and I mean
every year in August now because you can
see a little bit better in this picture
because of the location of the community
like I said originally it was a rural
sort of undeveloped area in albany new
york very similar to the south there was
only about one there was one dirt road
that you could read that you could use
to reach the community right here you
see the main street right there that's
washington avenue in albany new york
that was built in the 70s as a way of
people getting in there once that road
was built developers came in and saw
this as a great opportunity like there's
all this land out here you know we can
make buildings they built them all I
said it's a great opportunity for
development is like this you know
undeveloped area here's another picture
you can
see where r at road runs the two between
the two red dots and again Washington
Avenue so like I said the mall was built
one of the things that we've been
struggling with now is with the
construction of the mall and other
settlements people now it's come up
again where they see the land is an
opportunity to be developed so this
picture this article is from a group of
property management group that saw this
as an opportunity to build office
buildings one of the one of the original
homes was destroyed it was kind of run
down so the someone bought it just
demolished the home and so it as an
opportunity to build office buildings
well that would having an office
building right in the middle of a
residential historic community doesn't
really seem so when my family did is
they petition to not have that office
building be built and we actually won
that fight although the person still
owns the land they're not allowed to do
the office building so right now there's
still a conversation going on about how
we can develop this additionally this
has been a little more recent just in
the past few months there's a nursing
home nearby and they bought another
building I mean the original homes and
we're planning on believe demolishing it
but then you know this argument is still
going on saying you know that could take
away from the historic the historic
features of the community and those are
like pretty much the last slides that I
have but I just want to say our
positions here as social workers dealing
with issues of power and privilege and
disenfranchised and me from a policy
standpoint and one-on-one prevent this
from happening prevent people and
communities from having things taken
from them especially in relation to race
and ethnicity communities that are so
underprivileged and pushed down so much
how can we bring them up and encourage
them to rise up and keep the community
cohesion when you know other people can
come in and see like oh this is a great
opportunity for us to come in and take
advantage how do we prevent that
happening let's sort of the question
that I want to leave you guys with I
think we're going to have you might have
a chance for question and answers but
you